[Musique]
originaire du venezuela aïssa mais
adriana copropriétaire du restaurant
iberico ont craqué l'un pour l'autre et
pour la cuisine espagnole
les espagnols sont venus à la mairie du
sud
nous on a tout un mélange de cette
culture à part de nos origines
vénézuélien c'est comme ici à montréal
il est beaucoup de culture est une
richesse c'est ça qui on aime que les
personnes sans ici l'espérience espagnol
[Musique]
tomates ail et peint en trois plats tout
simple et nous font découvrir leur
version des tapas ces petites bouchées
unique trois maliens comme ça à mon sens
un peu traître est une table de tabac ça
n'a pas duré l'axé je vais faire oui
c'est des bons ingrédients marée basse
c'est raté face à eux pas cher et très
bon
bref un gros match parce
que chaque personne qui est mentionné
mme bligh le ponton tomates et on va
juste frotter à est sur une pente avant
de frotter la tomate correctement qui
sont extrêmement mur c'est parfait parce
que on lui coupait à moitié et on fait
je vous ai gratté sous les pins on a
déjà hâte au stick après ça à l'huile
d'olive un peu de sel sel de mer
fragments dans certaines régions
d'espagne on ne met pas die sur le pain
[Musique]
le pan con tomate et en andalousie
première manche pour y déjeuner mais
c'est pas tout le monde qui mangent de
la et le matin fort comme ça et les
bonnes choses c'est qu'ici vous savez
des options même tout seul avec les gens
vont aller avec fromage c'est l'option
que pourrait manger comme petit déjeuner
comment longe aussi une pour tacchella
mon petit a pas avec hyper devez vous
pouvez partager vous pouvez mélanger
avec une porte à coups on n'a jamais
assez du pan con tomate et non sa
première chose à manger en espagne je
suis tombé en bas de ma chaise je vais
goûter comme ça parce que tout est
parfait
tout le panache est tellement c'est un
peu de jambon ibérique sur le pagne
quant au matin et si le bonheur c'est le
cas le jambon la sacer du jambon iberico
de villota c'est un produit complètement
unique
dans les tapas on trouve aussi de
nombreuses variations à base de poissons
et de fruits de mer comme celle ci fait
de moules conservés dans une marinade à
base d'huile et de vinaigre qu'on
appelle escabèche y en a plusieurs
préparations pour escabèche de moi
j'avais une simple dont canal auraient
eux-mêmes troisième gardien aïe tomates
pain et on va juste a ajouté le ministre
moi j'aime beaucoup le clic de pinto n'a
pas pu être espagnol après que je fais
je retire mon âge j'ai juste eu un peu
de fabricants pagnol pour un côté
piquant fumée le sage mais on devinait
que mon tomates et je fais tout qu
après ça on va les coquilles et on va
créer une conserve de poisson qui va
nous amène ta pas complètement différent
sur la table mais avec les mêmes
ingrédients que ces jeux sont faits
juste de poser la main sur la soupe un
pli autre pilier de ses très douce très
bon
parce qu'après ça on peut prendre des
mots de mon prêt pensant dit non
toujours composé de notre trio de base
soit tomates ail effet le troisième
place la soupe salle mourir a difference
arras bat chaud je prends de tomates
gelé vide c'est plus une émission c'est
plus une tueuse plus crémeux c'est plus
pour moi je vois voilà voilà je mets des
lay mais là et moi je les branchies
trois fois ça y est vous l'agressivité
on va garder juste parfum des lay que
canada qui est des fois quand c'est trop
fort mais c'est trop fort voilà ça
serait juste utile
c'est bon un peu d'huile d'olive pour
l'onctuosité et des croûtons de pain les
pins qui a été oublié si les pins que ya
trois jours pour en manger c'est quand
les gars on n'est juste pas cette
précieux comme prévu moi je le garde on
reste rien des robots au bon moment j'ai
un bon cinq minutes
si on aime ça un peu plus ce chantier en
plus avaient quand même comme ça sinon
tard et à linselles pas assez noir ami
ou un choix sûr safer this plus délicat
et on le garde au froid moi j'irai 24
heures
juste pour que toutes les savants
mélanges et ça serait idéal à issam
ajoute une garniture à base d'oeuf cuit
base il y ait petits croûtons de chaud
[Musique]
ses frais je ferai mais en même temps ça
oui répond non ça que c'est quand même
c'est complexe quelque chose qui
j'adore ça démarre donc j'oubliais je
tenterai de faire une entrevue ou deux
je pense qu'un délai chose qu on aime de
la nourriture espagnoles sic et à la
maintenance et l issue pourrait manger
léger à la mi temps c'est un bon produit
mais moi ce que j'aime la nourriture
espagnoles en plus de tout ce que tu
veux dire c'est que ça m'oblige à manger
la fois conviviale on goûte à plein
plein plein de choses on passe un bon
moment sega joiret tapas c'est toujours
la fête
[Musique]